hey really quickly short library a lot
of people asked if we were going to do
anything special for two million
subscribers like we said we just wanted
to focus on the work continue creating
content that hopefully you know and love
please subscribe at the notification
bell if you haven't already hit the
notification bell because subscriptions
will necessarily mean a whole lot and
Mudd Club is what keeps this going so
right now if you enter in the promo code
at lot of credit calm slash mug Club two
million the number two million you get
$20 off and it ends Friday at 11:59 p.m.
I think Eastern that promo code is
number 2 million enjoy the show
[Music]
louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's June which Marx lager with
Crowder's third annual cultural
appropriation month where we appreciate
and appropriate all the great cultures
that this world has to offer
this week we whisk you away to the
ancient and reigning world champions and
violations of human rights undefeated
[Music]
it's like a pointer man very unwieldy
[Music]
poppers fine Papi's fight a to the death
to call your first board vice totally
fine he's not even a person behind - he
just sleepy yeah a whole lot for a
twofer before we get to anything else
some fun Egypt facts of course this is
the second to last week and cultural
appropriation month you send in you win
a costume contest every single week or
as the best costume before you do
anything eat of facts number one
parasites actually caused men to urinate
blood they were so common that the
Egyptians thought that men had menstrual
cycles that is a true fact number two
true facts are gross yeah ii always kept
several naked slaves nearby whose bodies
were smeared in honey in order to keep
the Flies from getting too close to him
so practical ladies man chivalry's not
dead
also women aren't granted citizenship at
all i don't know we have been Shapiro on
the show we've anthony Kumi on the show
today i'm happy to have back and we have
a Richard painter on the show and the
coach of the South Korean soccer team
whose name escapes me because I can't
pronounce it yeah young producing with
me in video studios always as dear to is
not gay follow on Twitter at not kid you
meet us cried or with your comments your
thought your photo shops your costumes
this we up I fulfill my obligations
drawing conclude conclusion somebody
help me
are we good we're good now we'll fix
that in post at G Morgan Jr what's the
wine of the day Pharaoh moans Pharaoh
oh I see did I thought you're gonna have
yeah Manischewitz but you actually
thought of Egypt are those boils on your
face or is that like zit cream
you look like Linus if he did an ad for
Clearasil thank you appreciate that I
think it's supposed to be some kind of a
skin disease yeah sperm computer are you
ready are the overlays I'm ready with
you yeah I'm a little sad the Angel of
Death killed killed both my babies but
they gave me opportunity to learn how to
juggle so that's that's good least they
were designed for a purpose yeah but
it'll start though I'm so sad and what
will cheer me up though is if people
find a way to be in follow me yet so no
see what happened there question of the
day before we get to NATO topics listen
with the situation with the deportation
of the families the border and Trump
being blamed for it and Facebook and
Twitter the average of politicians are
we supposed to assume that nobody now
has
anymore to actually know where this cop
from where this policy stems will talk
about this with ben shapiro will give
you a brief timeline after this I am
amazed tell me I want to hear from you
guys what you think because a lot of
people started off the week when I can't
believe President Donald Trump did this
and said oh this is effectively been in
effect since 97 what's happened these
pictures are from 2014 what's wrong also
second question do all Asians look alike
I contend that not all but most oh yeah
the vast majority we actually covered a
story that said that I'll talk to you
better in a minute yeah we're gonna talk
about a minute it's part of the funniest
story I've seen all week aside from the
dumpster fire
so to start off with a little good news
a lot of people say sometimes a little
bit dark when you start the show so some
of the sliver of light today Peter Fonda
was ripped from his Beverly Hills home
and shipped to timeshare with Kevin
Spacey so that's a good way to start the
day there we go
Spacey looks a little too happy to be
surprised it's appointed it's not good
for him well I think there's at a
certain point you're so old that you're
young again no it's like high-waisted
jeans fear you're to lose your eyesight
only with confetti so this videos gone
viral this week Democratic US Senate it
you said it at Senate guys got some
Harun no I can't pronounce my words the
Democrats gave a democratic whatever a
Senate a candidate for this US Senate
who's a Democrat Minnesota I've got to
say my name say my name got that one
Minnesota uh this is not a joke Richard
painter
this was his ad in its entirety take a
look
some people see a dumpster fire and do
nothing but watch the spectacle some are
too scared to face a danger or they
think it will benefit them if they just
let it keep on burning others shrug and
say oh all this talk of a dumpster fire
it's just fake boobs there is an inferno
raging in Washington but here in the
land of 10,000 lakes we know how to put
out a fire
hi I'm Richard painter and I approve
this message
so before you get mad at us he has not
had a stroke he is not how no no he's
definitely not out of stroke II there
was an interview may have but he
personally denied it that's that's what
Atticus says when you said interview he
said I was going to bring it up oh we
could say he looks like a [ __ ] Clint
Eastwood screwed a [ __ ] Ron Perlman
then have a stroke yes I'm trying to
think as bad as that ad is apparently
the taping of the the ad was actually
way worse and you know we get our hands
on exclusive foot we have a lot of
plants here at levels Crowder and we
actually have some some real some b-roll
or somehow it takes of some exclusive
footage from that ad some people see it
dumpster fire do nothing but watch the
spectacle some are too scared to face
record low unemployment Rick and a job
participation a booming stock market
intervene the pundits survey three or
four Asian American cities are plagued
by Dempster fans only you can prevent
dumpster fires by voting for me so
dumpster fire is a term that all the
kids are using now it's thermally okay
it's cool the nerd the seed I took a
dump in the fire
Donald Trump took a dump in the fair the
fire it was always burning when trend
started turning
temperature first can we say kirbridge
fear it's easier for me to save and
dumpster fare the buyers the land of a
thousand leaks here in the land of a
million leaks we have a lot of lakes
here in Minnesota at least we used to
the fur all the dumpster fairs is it as
simple as that America I think so when
you think Richard painter Hey
dumpster fair Richard painter for US
Senate because only he can prevent
observers that's why I'm always change
my mind I've talked about this I am the
least objective person at watching
anything that we do that isn't
character-driven yeah I have to trust
you guys in like listen just i can't
watch myself please let me know how this
turns out he had no one around him to
say no this is a disaster zone and they
just got done capitalizing on
embarrassing conservative ads and then
their own team does and i noticed they
do that the leftist blogs has never show
the video they just put on quotes it's
only in quotes they don't want to show
you yeah it's just it's like woat lee
screenshots because they want they've
been cast the film before they've had a
live read speaking of these lines ringo
Fleming by the way the BBC has a new
report on the Arab world's quote only
gay radio station station plays music
and issues are discussed in depth but
LGBTQ contributors LGBTQ they haven't
added the QIO a little on the they don't
identify themselves as sexually active
on-air come to the roof so really um if
you actually listen to radio it's it's
just gay karaoke with the lyrics changed
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like okay well I'll just have to take
your word for it if I'm not tuning in
for it's not getting my heart to radio I
don't care they've gained everything I
don't want none of your mailings tell me
I was coming the bagels pooping is
dangerous and creates the same pain as
childbirth for sloths I knew this is
just a it's a sloth only release their
bobbles once a week the act of pooping
occurs in the forest floor which can be
a dangerous place for sloths as
predators lurk there and matters are
made even worse when they reach sloths
digest so it's about half of the sloths
fatalities occur doing this rich know
they refer to as a ritual I just thought
I don't know like this just goes to tell
that the endangered species list is
[ __ ] yes it's complete another crime
of looting if we stopped hunt I don't
know if anyone's hunting sloths but if
we stopped all of it tomorrow half of
them would still die from pooping 50%
chance of dying they say at the toilet
or actually 100% if you're famed rock
star sloth sloth Presley or Elvis la
flee to the animation he's still alive
but I'm like with childbirth you'd have
to hear the sloths complain about
constipation for nine months oh it is
true lots of constipation that I I read
about the annual pony festival yeah it's
just happened it's not what you think
where people compete in events and
classes just the same as real horses
this is where and these events are very
competitive just like a regular horse
show we end up people go down over and
jump you failed at a pony festival sir
this is that's what I watched that clip
look you failed at a human foot meeting
okay let me put this in a context
there's normal society okay
superior by the way to Pony fetishists
in every way okay then there's a long
layer including ventriloquist social
justice warriors an X Fox News hosts
soccer players and finally there's Pony
fetishes and then there's you even
Carrie is looking down from heavens
think that's kind of embarrassing
Macaulay Culkin was like what do you do
with your life they say this comes from
the only kid Michael Jackson I think it
was just a genius move I love how dear
old wasn't saying anything today
Oh quiet well he's grieving this next
one's right down center plate for you
two people were arrested in Oklahoma
City for having drunken sex in the
middle of an intersection well nothing
would sound out of the ordinary until
you see their mug shots look at the mug
shots woman pleaded not guilty to charge
the bestiality in the great state of
Oklahoma includes but is not limited to
the rock eater from the neverending
story what your face looks like a your
face looks like a cliff you know you
must have a huge I get laid in an
intersection I don't care how drunk she
was but Your Honor in my defense I was
so wasted I thought he was the nothing I
was buzzed he looked like a tray you we
made some bad decisions oh what a good
movie I regret all the things mostly
living in Oklahoma no but I'm fortunate
to have the child in my life oh my gosh
giving her it's gonna be painful come on
a passing the biggest kidney stone ever
so Dale Altman's now a marijuana farmer
was cut off by the erupting a Chloe
volcano he refused to give up on his
dream claiming that it's his main source
of income and that quote we are not
stupid we thought this out
he says if you look at that image with
the LOB there's nothing left but he has
no power left yeah we're all sitting
here laughing but he actually comes to a
long line of experienced narcotic
creators and distributors like his
brother actually who grows opium poppies
in the tornado Valley so he's a good
there you go
yeah and his uncle who built a meth lab
next to the lair of Godzilla yeah
insights 20/20 hindsight is always 20/20
and I pick about our spots I mean
there's Walmart parking lots everywhere
I will not leave my pot plants even
though I literally molten lava acid
ranges the skin and air that burns your
lung cavity but I'm not addicted anytime
I want realized even this big farmer
suppresses the fact that marijuana cures
Milton arms yes yes yes its topic pharma
created the volcano which by the way
doesn't exist because the earth is flat
and it would go like this I've seen the
video let's just go through this real
quick because what will really quickly
will speak with ben shapiro about it
trump by the way didn't separate
families this is a whole bunch of
misdirected outrage let's just do a
quick timeline to clear this up okay
sometimes actual journalism happens
first off even it's family
Jason point Britt Baldwin called out I'm
like at her board for Tammy Baldwin over
the blatant hypocrisy look at the clip
so many people in this country are
certainly outraged by the cages and the
thermal blankets and the facilities
housing these kids you know they were
all there in 2014 under President Obama
and my question to you senator Baldwin
is did you speak up against them then
you know on the on this issue that we
trying to I was just lucky that
Broadmoor that's a bold question
actually everyday I'm not joking in my
prayers I ask that he'll come on the
show it's in 2018
that's a bold question are you serious
it's for CNN I mean she just saved come
on this cheenu shouldn't have the answer
take zero balls to ask that question
okay for you she has no balls well you
didn't have to say it this is so the
floor is consent policy by the way was
signing the law under Clinton okay in
1997 direct quote prohibits the federal
government from keeping children in
immigration detention even if they are
with their parents for more than twenty
days okay
that's when the New York Times it's not
fake news okay Republican all right face
book pages from the New York Times your
own sources yes these are your own
sources the Obama administration
violated this policy of course they
angered immigration advocates saying you
detain mothers and their future release
okay so this week agencies began
enforcing the immigration law with a
zero tolerance policy has been increased
yes and parents being detained of course
and children being released into these
what they call tender care facilities I
know I'm not a big fan of the name
either it's amazing what happens what
happens to statistics when you go from
0% enforcement to 100% exactly 100% if
you go from 0% to any person to any
percent and yesterday of course Donald
Trump signed an executive order to end
all this because you can't you know the
polls yeah children live them from 2014
just so you know so that's what we'll
talk about more anything else that I
missed I just think we've lost our
ability to have rational thought with
this this is crazy it's a no-win
situation on both sides 14 Obama's crazy
for doing it now Trump's crazy for doing
it it's like you can't win can we just
build a wall please and be done soccer
team on the border I don't know what is
just so stupid about this Bibi is that
the executive and the transformation
administration is blamed for executing
the law I know it's a legislative straw
to change it yeah but the only acting
like Trump as a guy
he just recites what is being done
exactly well did he decide to
unfortunate yeah these agents decided to
start a four songs laws but exactly it
is the law that's the issue now if you
have someone who doesn't respect rule of
law it doesn't mean that the rule of law
is not a thing that it's a figment of
your imagination and it doesn't mean
that it's a human right to be a citizen
of the United States that was the big
thing we did the change my what changed
my mind I build the wall people said why
did you pick this as like a struck that
really were there repeat was Austin
there were professors there was no one
who had any kind of a coherent argument
it was just the walls kind of mean so
we're gonna do it again and hopefully
get something a little bit more
substantive from people but it was
really tough it was hard to pick which
ones to run because no one made a valid
look at like a really competitive
argument no I could nothing convincing
we can paint some cartoon on it then we
gate we gave you the best if we gave you
the cream of the crop yeah what you get
back pac-man all right so another story
that I think is the funniest thing I've
ever heard in my life
south it's the true story I'm gonna be
asking it could do all Asians look alike
or is it racist to think that so South
Korean coach of the soccer team I'm on a
show Shin Taeyang Shin tae-yong I don't
know I have no idea it's he's good he
admitted to pulling a little switcheroo
mixing around the jersey numbers recent
training sessions and warm-up games
because he believes Westerners find it
difficult quote to distinguish between
Asia yeah she did it more specifically
to confuse the Swedes during practice by
the way Snopes it refuses it check true
zero Pinocchio's we'll all right I do
have to be careful with this maybe I'm
gonna pull it back a little so here a
comment action on the controversy now is
South Korean soccer coach I think we
have a right [ __ ] shouldn't a Shin
tae-yong thanks for being here he's so
happy
yeah there's no way it's going to go
well so mr. Jung explain to us why
you're at the center right now this
controversy is jersey around just play
no danger okay right so you had players
exchange jerseys but why and do it to
mess with the Swedes this is another
joke so the bass just makes up players
no danger so you thought they wouldn't
be able to tell your players apart if
they switched jerseys is that what
telepods well I see you guys my boy if
you can't certainly not some filthy
Swede just playing oh like kill Joe no
danger I don't think anyone's
insinuating danger here I'm afraid now
to see all Asians look alike but let me
let you in on the secret this here we
are look alive I know I don't think I
don't think that okay let me show you if
you wouldn't take our Ford some come in
and describe him to police sketch artist
what do you say
I don't know black hair maybe maybe
brown eyes a relatively short oval face
okay okay now if you look at Wong Yuen
he Chen our strike darling how do you
describe him to bullies how you what
would you say well yeah yeah black black
hair Kim Sun Yong Tae Yong he knock up
hole digger store how you describe him
probably black hair brown eyes and nose
piercing eyes you're just a joke no
danger how could time that kid tell my
kids up hi Steven I can look at the test
scores really yes I don't beat the wrong
long with the violin arrived
wait what see here's my point if the
world cup the stupid County sweets can't
even tell South Korea's most famous
successful soccer players when it comes
to the [ __ ] what are your local
bodegas you know gosh no boss chance and
hail Steve I'm just very uncomfortable
all this I don't think that this is
going oh you might are so uptight why
are you so uncomfortable what you're
expressing your frankly it sounds a
little racist even for this show I would
say oh it's racist I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry I didn't know it was racist but
let me tell you did it work it did your
work it actually does seem to have
worked according to the article not even
the coach what website has been a key
point a Tracy's don't work no no you
know that can't be the lesson here
you're gonna have to go copy dressed Kim
young-sam like girl what I see you then
South Korean soccer coach in Taeyang of
no no more no more oh yes he finds me
yeah I hope he finds me coach
okay but you know what he opened the
door for me I felt I had to pull back
now we can put our foot on the guest
here we go here's the thing if it is an
actual strategy for South the South
Korean soccer coach to take the most
famous South Koreans on earth by the way
if a South Korean actor is famous he's
only famous in South Korea a South
Korean soccer player is probably the
closest thing to an international
celebrity that exists from South Korea
right so only thing wrong yeah so the
most famous South Koreans on earth all
they had to do was switch the number and
their chief opposition the Swedes
watching them practice could not tell
the difference that was all it took was
a Jersey swap and you know that you need
to change sizes knows no tailoring going
on at night a little bit one size fits
every Asian so I wonder like kick the
door get mad but here's the truth I
think we need to litigate between racism
which is hate which is believing that
someone is inferior because of their
race and this this faux colorblindness
acting as though it's somehow virtuous
to to not acknowledge the differences
between races yeah doesn't mean we make
up differences between you I'm trying to
think about a trip I'm trying to pick my
words well you're here fully but I'm not
so so what I was gonna say is we
actually covered this on morning
grinders mate rest in peace we there was
an f-22 cell phone they were doing the
facial recognition feature for the
iPhone yeah and there was two Asian
ladies and it couldn't decipher one lady
was able to open it every time they take
a back seat right
it's scientific proof no sorry doctor I
actually didn't most people have
difficulty differentiating faces from
other races and it's not just white
people they it's called other race or
the cross race effect yeah yeah there's
an actual psychological they've studied
this pretty I think you brought up the
overlay right there yeah from psychology
today so but they'll be turned into hate
speech tomorrow well basically just yeah
you know no matter what what race you're
talking about if you member of One race
you'll have a lot easier job deciding
who looks different right yeah but yeah
that's the same for Asians and blacks
and everyone and pretty much it also
said and one of the studies that it has
nothing to do with racism or like
yeah I think so but instead he's in the
cross race effect some some have noted
that participants had the most
difficulty telling surprise Asian faces
apart so the quote is in particular the
most mistakes happen to take in the face
of a male Chinese 68% Indian 58 percent
female Indian and then female Chinese
that's that's a walk away win the honors
trend there's just very little variance
between yeah within those races it's
just a physical appearance is very
little very everyone here right there's
a there's a foot of height difference
between you right and spend computer
almost yeah and there's different eye
colors different hair on all everyone
different facial hair abilities
different body types and different skin
tone yeah you can't go in the Sun no I
can spend computer probably can't just
because Angela Merkel won't allow them
to I'm not saying it all Asians look
alike but there is statistically less
variability you can also say the same
thing not just about Asians this is
again why it's so important just this
isn't racism as the study said it's not
about hate it's about recognizes
recognizing that people of different
races look different you said something
about a slight Icelandic people right
now picture an Icelandic person your
head okay
what do you think probably taller more
fair-skinned blonde hair when you think
of a Viking I think if someone from
Scandinavian country more likely to look
some probably a socialist right been
thinking of the master race over here
easy same thing same thing of your
picture a black person right now on your
head you probably chewing someone are
there black people with blue eyes with
it yes absolutely of the hodgetwins but
most of them have black hair brown eyes
dark skin no sickle cells that's is a
thing disproportionate rates racist
German they're also cooler and this is
something I think that races to note
that the story was so funny to me
because when anyone that when when when
the rubber hit the road
the South Korean soccer coach it's like
The Parent Trap but with a whole race
well that's the thing too that's the
people what they think of you the
cultural appropriation Mexicans are the
first one who sells street tacos and
sombreros yeah I might throw that first
ones to make money off of him like yeah
this is what we do this is the Mexican
it sent they'll at least offended by it
Jerry couch with us my mother is
french-canadian god bless her and she is
not and when she didn't encounter many
black people and I've never seen
don't like them I'm cold weather come
one said hey you did a church saying you
did a great job I loved you playing the
piano well you know actually this church
you know the church was a church we
didn't go to and here's the thing it was
a different guy and it was a different
black guy that said my mom that's a good
one up to complement him and they were
the same height same build yeah same
Hale color same eye color and that day
they were both wearing a maroon sweater
yeah I know she's gonna be mad at we've
done this story it's a compliment she
said she'd say hey you look the guy who
stole my radio know exactly that hateful
you want to see how much culture's care
about this kind of stuff watch the World
Cup I'm sorry I have to work this in the
Egypt the Egyptian the Egyptian fans
we're wearing what he is wearing what
not get Jared's wearing they were
wearing that yeah it'll care they really
I swear to you they were some the head
not the whole thing
the header they were wearing the
headdress kind of thing there I swear to
you look it up you have to watch soccer
for it though I don't believe you come
on what a play line I think you're being
racist I don't care I don't participate
in soccer you should know I don't race
this is a case in point is this exactly
it's racist because of South Korean
soccer team this is one thing I think
people have been made so afraid of
having you're not even necessarily of
having opinions but also of observing
statistical realities yeah listen these
are the same people by the way who are
offended if you say on average Asian
people have higher IQs more of them
getting to college in the United States
it's not how could you say that by the
way it's true we have to have an opera
ever reverse quota for Asians in college
that's a thing we can only take so many
it actually exists because a farce left
policy right they get upset about that
but then when a South Korean soccer
coach does the old switcheroo we say hey
you can only do that because you know
they'll have black hair brown eyes and
oval faces all of a sudden it's a thing
no we're gonna say it we're totally fine
with it and by go watch the documentary
we can have been cheap Europe go watch
the documentary too funny to fail and
there's a funny sketch in that where
Stephen Colbert Steve Carell Dana Carvey
they were all robbed rich Michael they
were all talking about this and there's
people in the crowd who were kind of
these stereotypes one was a Saudi person
I think one was Asian and Steve Carrell
said today it would be career-ending ly
racist but back then it was okay it was
a joke and it wasn't at all meant to be
mean-spirited and I watched it and I
thought about this with anything come
here I was thinking my gosh you absolute
pansy the fact that you you consider
that racist you consider that off-limits
for jokes
what is gone what does comedy going to
be in five years from now mr. Colbert
I can't command it so um thank you South
Korea for swapping the jerseys and
letting this joke go on a little longer
bench for your next
[Music]
Dollar Shave Club bloody business doctor
razors in fact you're just getting
started
me personally oh yeah think about
starting my dad other citrus Hawaiian
ginger face cleanser there good shake
hand cream or there fluoride toothpaste
of course the razors aren't half bad but
you already knew that
how are you back there better perfect in
the spring about Dollar Shave calm slash
Crowder is actually great way to try
dollars but we don't have that many
sponsors on this show
usually not by choice but for five
dollars you get their daily essential
starter set it comes to the body
cleanser that one wipe Charlies amazing
about whips they work fantastically
famous shave butter and of course their
their best razor and then for a few
bucks more you can keep those razors
coming listen if you groom anyway use
these products support a great sponsor
who's not shying away in sponsoring this
show and and and you're gonna use
something any which as good as anything
else out there so that is Dollar Shave
calm slash crowd of five dollars to
sample the whole kit and you won't be
disappointed unless you don't groom then
find another channel when our next guest
was in Egypt land let my I think you can
guess who it is you know his show you
love is show at the daily wire at Ben
Shapiro as long as they allow him and
apparel he's talking to someone else
who's not me right now but that's just
been yeah here you do it I mean it's
just it there we go there you go and
they got a pipe in the volume louder
there you go how are you mr. Shapiro
well I'm good I mean I have to tell you
I'm a little uncomfortable your your
prom dress is not my that my culture is
not your prom dress my friend no it's
not your culture its Egypt's culture
just you appropriated the Jews the Jews
that were appropriated by Egypt and now
we're appropriating from Egypt so that
we give it back to you he liberated the
Jews and then they complain in the
desert when they had many doctors
[Laughter]
mana fueled by it alright Ben we were
just talking about this before with a
timeline and I know I've been following
you as well this immigration Fiasco this
week as far as the media and its
handling of it here's a deal like we
talked about Donald Trump make some
mistakes but do people think that we
can't Google this and see which policy
this was when it was signed how it's
being enforced explained for people who
don't believe me because I don't have
that much credibility today the timeline
so the timeline is that in 1997 the
Clinton administration signed an
agreement called the Flores agreement
with a bunch of advocates for illegal
immigrants and the Flores agreement the
settlement agreement basically suggested
that parents that unaccompanied minors
who come to the southern border could
not be held in custody for longer than
20 days right in 2014-2015 there's this
big wave of migrants that comes up to
the border with kids as parents with
kids and the Obama administration
decides they want to hold the parents
and the kids there together and they
actually called the deterrent at the
time J Jackson who is Jay Johnson rather
who's the head of DHS he said at the
time this is a deterrent policy designed
to keep people from coming to the United
States there's a lawsuit filed against
that policy of keeping the children with
the parents together in detention on the
basis of the flora settlement the Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals rules that if
you arrest the parents you cannot keep
the kids in custody longer than 20 days
the kids have to be released out of
custody they cannot be held with the
parents so Trump comes along and he says
listen we're not going to just catch and
release these people anymore so what
Obama did in response was he basically
said okay we're not gonna arrest anyone
he were gonna come across the border
with their kids we're just gonna hold
them for a second then we'll release
them and then we will trust them to come
back well this resulted in a very high
rate of people not showing up for court
as you'd imagine to look for in ten
people not showing up for court they
just disappear in the imperialist
traffic tickets only with losers yeah
that's exactly right so in 2017 2018 the
Trump administration makes clear they
are now going to put into place the no
tolerance policy the zero tolerance
policy where everybody who comes across
the border illegally will now be
prosecuted as an illegal immigrants if
you want to apply for asylum you go to a
point of entry no problem you want to
try and immigrate legally you go to a
point of entry
no problem you try to cross the border
where there is no border patrol and they
will arrest you and they will charge you
criminally no what that means is that
thanks to that reenactment of the Flores
settlement under 2016 Ninth Circuit law
you arrest the parents who cannot keep
the kids in custody with the parents
there must be separated by policy so it
wasn't the Trump was like you know what
let's grab these families and then
separate out the kids because I hate
children they're the worst and I want to
murder them know what round children
respite severely brown children as we've
been told exactly when when it's just
like the Nazis instead what it really
was was it was going to be President
Trump arresting everyone who comes
across the border and if the natural
after effect of that is the kids can't
be held in custody then they're
separated for a given period of time
until they are deported as a family if
they apply for asylum that time is a
little bit longer right and if they
don't apply for asylum and then the
court process moves pretty quickly for
deportation the kids get deported
alongside the parents the media instead
proclaim this is Japanese internment
this is Nazi policy it's brand-new now
the way that you know this was absolute
crap the way that you know this is
absolute crap is not only because the
Obama administration did it but also
because when the when the Trump
administration does it then the
suggestion is if they separate the
families is the worst thing ever right
you got Rachel Maddow weeping openly on
television yeah but if they bring the
families back together in detention then
the suggestion is that this is inhumane
so if you separate the families it's
inhumane and Nazi ask if you bring the
families together it's like the Japanese
internment camps meaning the only
solution the left is proposed here is
just release everyone back to the
general society right which of course is
what they're looking which is when I
asked myself what would Kevin Spacey do
I probably centered the cages here's the
thing I just said all of the things that
bench Bureau said in the earlier segment
I just wanted to make sure that you
heard it from someone who people believe
knows your trust no that's exactly right
and this is a good example of where I've
talked about this where we did to change
my mind a lot people go well I didn't
like this one because you're usually
civil I'm not going to be civil based on
a lie
and we talked about build the wall
people started talking about dreamers
people start talking about anchor what
about the kids were hearing okay
everyone obviously is compassionate but
you don't want to deport felons you want
open borders so before we get that far
down the trail to try and find common
good not been by the way I'm talking
about the people of change I'm right
before we try and act as though we can
find common ground on what to do with
children let's figure out what we do
with the bulk of illegal immigration and
there is no common ground and that's
what you see right now it's appeasing
crocodiles Donald Trump separates them
he's a monster
puts them back together he's a monster
the only solution is again where we have
no common gun open borders completely
now I will say that the Trump
administration did botched the rollout
of the
policy and magnificent fashion as per
our usual arrangement the Trump
administration has it has a policy and
the policy is perfectly defensible on
the merits and instead of just rolling
out the policy saying listen we have a
zero tolerance policy we'd prefer to
change the law so kids can stay with
their parents in detention facilities
before they are removed on mass instead
of doing that he has a bunch of people
tried out there to say that he wants to
use the separation of the children as a
deterrent in and of itself which is
idiotic and then say well we didn't
really mean that what we really meant if
you'd like to keep everybody together
and then say but we can't keep everybody
together because the legislature has to
solve that which is correct and but we
the executive branch can't just sign an
executive order getting rid of this and
then after about a week blow back say
well you know well sign an executive
order and we'll sort of get rid of it
and we'll sort of not get rid of it
therefore undercutting the entire legal
basis for what you've been claiming for
two weeks and making you look malicious
and stupid like there's no reason that
it had to be rolled out this way it's
the worst rollout of any policy that
they've had since the travel ban and
again there's there's no rationale for
it because again it is perfectly
defensible
on the legal merits you know as a lawyer
I'm the legal merits this is a perfectly
defensible policy it is just not
defensible to to switch in time all the
time we're touring with the Russian
opera playing violin for a while but
then I remember you were a lawyer you
were my lawyer I was your lawyer I was
that was the ultimate Jews lawyer it's
amazing I know I'm uncomfortable I feel
like I don't know I don't know what's
going on here
know that I'll sue them but one thing I
definitely have definitely honest with
you you find yourself defending the
policies of the Trump administration
more and more well of course listen the
PR debacle so here's the deal when we
talked about this there to the polls as
well where people don't support well
until he's on the executive order people
did not support the separation of
families but people over well a
plurality of people I think was 46 to 37
you probably remember the stat from
earlier this week do support stricter
immigration laws and enforcement of
borders so that shows you there's a
disconnect between what Americans want
and what they perceive is happening
according to the media and yes Donald
Trump gives them a little bit of a gift
that being said you can't use it this is
what the left is doing taking this
debacle and using it to argue for the
fact that well the laws haven't been
enforced therefore it's a human right to
be in the United States of America yeah
exactly right and then again the the TEL
is pretty obvious here Ted Cruz says
okay well here's the fix and Chuck
Schumer who five seconds ago was saying
this is Japanese internment and nazism
saying well you know we're not gonna
work with you on that fix
to hold from feet to the fire I was like
well either it's Nazism and you should
try to stop it or it's not Nazism and
you're just lying about right and it
turns out that it's the second and of
course now that that the Trump
administration has signed this executive
order which by the way is is legally
vacuous I mean they're there it really
is an empty executive order it either
reinstates catch and reinstitute catch
and release or it doesn't change policy
at all from what the Trump
administration was already doing it just
kind of puts a nicer face on it yeah but
once there like you're saying that's
kind of what's needed right now that's
that is what's needed is a nicer face on
it because something is you know I
disagree the executive order to the
extent that I think that it I think it's
foolish because he's not gonna win any
points with people who hate him they're
just going to support that he is an
inhuman monster and I also think that it
doesn't it's not operative it's just
legally not operative what he should
have done is you should have said here's
a piece of draft legislation I came up
with with you know Ted Cruz and whomever
else is gonna propose this if Democrats
don't support it it's because they
obviously don't want to fix the problem
right exactly that I think would have
been a better PR tactic as opposed to
putting a nice face on is what I'm
saying because you know the Democrats
wouldn't get behind it either way you're
putting a nice face on something that
has to be done that would have been am
all right I just don't think that the
nice face is going to succeed because
you're gonna have Samantha be out there
immediately suggesting that the
executive order is now about ripping
children away from freedom and putting
them in jail this is what she did on her
execrable show last night she surely won
and I've had this this running tally for
four years his four way running gun
battle for the least funny human being
in America it was always between
Samantha bee Trevor Noah Lena Dunham and
Amy Schumer and in the last several
weeks
I mean Samantha bee is like Secretariat
she has just bolted away from the pack
it is astonishing ya know exactly if you
could combine her with the face of Sarah
Jessica Parker she would be secretary I
think I think you're mostly correct here
I think either way there needs to be a
band-aid put on as far as the PR issue
that's what I'm talking about the
Americans perceives most Americans want
enforcement of the law that was one
thing we noticed would have changed my
mind when we did to build the wall
people came up and said yeah they agreed
with everything except they said I think
a wall is mean and they go a wall is not
going to do anything we go home a second
what if it were to do something it's a
piece of the puzzle
Americans are definitely tired of
nothing being done with the illegal
immigration and politicians are using
this for football right now so it's it's
a quagmire it's absolutely a quagmire
but you know they took our jobs
I mean this is this is why I've never
been a fan of the whole idea of
comprehensive immigration can
a comprehensive immigration bills and
all this nonsense because if you take
each one of these policies in a vacuum
people know what the right thing to do
is you just say a wall alone people like
yeah
makes perfect sense if you say okay we
got to enforce the border people like
makes perfect sense if you say family
should stay together people say makes
perfect sense and then you wrap it all
up and it's a one giant piece of crappy
legislation and pass it and then none of
it makes any sense anymore right that's
exactly right
all we the guy who said they should they
should have x-ray lasers at the borders
with people with tags and I was like you
want a tag and bag illegal immigrants
you make donald's taxes for that yes it
was uploaded online Hey so a message we
were talking about this not not too long
ago and I know you mentioned this Tommy
Robinson who's been on the show quite a
bit i yeah you said that you might have
had a misimpression of him a little bit
and obviously it's gotten worse since
you've talked about Tara now that he's
been moved to another Jin yeah I
corrected it i corrected on my show as
well so my original impression of him
when I first talked about him is I used
the descriptor far right which always
seems to be somewhere between alright
and not quite alright
and I should have known better than that
obviously because there are so many
people on left who call anyone all right
I'd seen some exalter quotes as well
right there are some soldier quotes
after the 77 London subway bombing where
he sort of impugn to all Muslims as
being responsible for that I looked at
that I said well that's pretty radical
stuff obviously he's apologized for that
he's moved away from that and so I did
read on air a piece by I'm trying to
member who was Douglas Douglas Murray
about his about Tommy Robinson and sort
of his background and they gave me a
fuller picture of who Tommy Robinson as
a guy who certainly has his troubles but
I think in many ways is trying to do the
right thing so yeah I wanted to you know
be a little more accurate than my
original depiction of him which was kind
of cursory and using descriptors that
are that are too big well I appreciate
that but I think that goes a long way
because we've done that too in this show
where this this is a difference with
what we do people can't really go after
our sponsors or get us fired but it also
means that we have to have a system of
self account kind of like hockey we have
to be our own enforcers and especially
now with what you see what's happening
with Tommy Tommy we've got a good friend
of the show he's a self-professed a
Zionist as well so I know a lot of
people have labelled him in all right
Nazi whenever I see that I go oh hold on
a second okay
maybe he's all but is he a Nazi I go
wait Lawson he's a huge supporter of
Israel he's not doing it for you he's
not doing it very well but somebody's
doing it better is probably Chuck
Schumer if he believes this is like aa
Smith's
imagine that well we can close off Fitz
but let's use it as leverage that's
what's going on now it really does D it
really does belittle the history of the
Holocaust when all of this is compared
to the Holocaust and then they well
effectively everything ever everything
is stupid apparently the only things
that anyone knows in America is they
once read part of a Harry Potter book
and they heard of these bad people
called the Nazis and so everything has
to fit into one of these two frameworks
either it's a reference to Hogwarts or
if I don't like it then it's a Nazi
these are the only if it's great it's
Harry Potter if it's bad it's a Nazi so
it's just I'm so glad that our political
conversations have boiled down to Harry
Potter Nazis and Kim Kardashian's ask
somehow achieving pardons in Harry
Potter they're not and it would make the
who make it make the whole thing much
more threatening I mean one of the big
problems with Harry Potter is how
confident is Voldemort if you can't even
take over like a high school yeah like
that that's he's really having a rough
time with this high school exactly
you're telling me is the worst character
in this entire universe and he can't
take over a high school he'd probably
have more success with a paneled van
labeled free puppies Hall this way he's
not a formidable foe now that I think
about it you said Lois per our
aspirations it's all one thing I will
say about Harry Potter my wife actually
because I did I was like this is
unwatchable I can't watch this and I was
like I know how it ends Harry Potter and
she lied to me and she told me that
Neville what his name is long Neville I
don't know the Neville Longbottom long
but I don't know but she's like he's the
real Harry Potter haha so now you have
to find out how they tie this all
together Harry Potter's and I was like
really and I watch it turns out she lied
and I watched the whole series hmm so
Wow I'm having an annulment your loving
husband I mean that's that's pretty
brutal right there
all of them hell of a prank and then
after that I took her to Harry Potter
world and I got violently ill so not the
biggest fan that's why I would do one I
don't remember the Nazis being mentioned
in the films but again I'm not one of
those people with Harry Potter's the
books were better because um I don't
hate myself
Ben so you are a daily wire and of
course you have a show coming up if I'm
not mistaken in
on August 15th Ben Shapiro live tickets
are available live nation.com right yeah
yeah absolutely you go over to Daly
wire.com slash events as well if you
want to check out the tickets there so
yeah we're almost sold out and it should
be it should be a blast got about 3,000
people who are showing up
oh yeah and we're looking forward to it
and one in Dallas we're doing one in
Phoenix I think the next night so our
first our first live podcast our first
live show so that should be fun
oh this is are you doing like what we
did at SMU taking the bench I didn't
know you're taking the Ben Shapiro show
on the road I thought you were doing
this just a speaking engagement but it's
the show la no it's not it's not like a
formal speech it's gonna be me kind of
riffing and then we'll do Q&A for a
while man that'll be fun why we'll tell
you too when we did at SMU was you know
same size and the protestors were it was
paltry and it wasn't even their signs so
they're not very invigorated in Dallas I
think you'll be mostly fine
definitely I'm definitely looking
forward to it so yeah I'll see you there
yeah no I'll stop by or or I'll just say
I'll stop by right now and your show and
I actually won't stop by it I'll just
ignore you when I can yeah that's
absolutely fine and then I'll just find
some angry angry left us in Austin and
tweet your address and I'll make sure to
get them through security and then I'll
have spent computer-like storming the
stage right before you deport it yes
haven't you heard were just as bad as
the left okay that is the Ben Shapiro
show at Daily wires Thank You Ben very
much I appreciate it brother
you look like you're working too much
getcha last hard to see my friend
[Music]
greetings America Harper here I just
want to tell you how touched I've been
so to all the people who join my club
I've been getting more teas and
blueberries and I just hope that I can
earn all the cheese's and blueberries
and I don't know why I have them but
somewhere in my you for childhood I must
have done something
[Music]
[Music]
we're not on television uh-oh so we
don't want to our next guest I'm very
happy to have him back it's been a while
I thought he was cross with us see yeah
because most people are and also
apparently I used terms from the 1930s
that are entirely unnecessary alarm
addiction le dumpster fire that's what I
should but you know him at the Kamiya
show on Twitter see whenever you have
several plugs people know exactly who it
is already and of course a compound
media the Anthony Kamiya show Kumi Akuma
show I always I always get the stuff
wrong sorry I was saying it wrong it's
flying
Anthony Koo Mia thanks for being back
sir love being back I haven't seen you
in a while no we don't have a beef
we're not cross with each other nothing
like that it's just yeah running these
kind of net you know this like running a
show and a network thing in this day and
age is a full-time job
yes it's very well you look good though
you got the haircut now and yet you look
you look younger yeah a little civilized
I figured I had to do it people I ask
people to contribute money to me for HD
video you don't want it to be too
gruesome for them so I figured I'd
better clean up a little bit now I'm
making the move to 4k yet no now we
won't be doing that I want the I want
that Vaseline lens like the women on old
Star Trek episodes you see where kami
Diaz is pockmarks hideout so that way we
never met actually yes there were a
couple people who you see in HD for the
first Cameron Diaz has a first one where
I I saw and I said oh that's not the
woman I had a crush on on the mask when
I was skin and facial hair really show
up in 4k it's crazy
and you know actually the work my father
makes an audible sound every time Maggie
Gyllenhaal is on the screen at a movie
theater he makes sure to go so the
people around him can hear go Oh which
is so unfortunate because her brother is
so gorgeous even as a straight man like
Jake Gyllenhaal I know that's a trend I
very rarely seen like I really talked a
man the sisters almost always kind of
Butch looking yeah I know kind of like
looks like the man yeah I think yeah it
probably worked that way where the the
guy gets a little bit of that FEM
hormone at in the womb and the girl has
to you know take the the bootlace Katie
Holmes
hey or you like Billy Joel you Mary
Christie Brinkley have a child she looks
like you shame all right Anthony so I
know you have some strong opinions on
what's been going we just talked about
this what's been going on with
immigration and ripping babies from
their mother's arms and Peter Fonda so
much has happened this week what first
off is that a real cigarette holder is
that a prank cigarette holder well it is
a cigarette holder but I imitate my
father with it it's my father it has to
go like that
Oh son of a [ __ ] Anthony simple common
sense and it puts me back there and and
tames me down a bit yeah I'll just make
sure you don't hug anyone else for a
couple of weeks and create a comp that's
right a little bit better so what's your
what's your read on this whole thing
this week we just talked about how
obviously these compounds existed with
with Obama and I I know you're pretty
media savvy it's so it's politically
motivated it's I can't I can't believe
anybody watches anyone on the Left
talked about this and actually goes yeah
yeah they do care they care about the
children because it's so obvious when
they use words like torn ripped from
their parents arms yes no one's be like
I haven't seen one video of give me that
kid you HOT you but I haven't seen one
video like that but it's just Kevin
Spacey yeah yeah they I haven't seen one
of those all I've seen our kids in in
new sneakers and nice clothes in a camp
looking atmosphere where there's arts
and crafts and PlayStation and food
plenty of food yeah and then it's of
course the Liberals have to take it to
that umpteenth level it looks like in
cages I think it's a Virgin America
they'd settle for I think it's I think
they're okay with it it's like it's
getting very difficult for people on the
left to lie to people because we we have
such availability to actually see and
feel things like when they talk about
the tax cuts being a terrible thing and
Pelosi will be like oh it's crumbs and
it's a bad thing
and then somebody actually gets their
paycheck it goes wait there's more money
in here
how much does someone have to lie to you
for you to go yeah and that's bad more
money like it's getting very difficult
for them to lights and when they say
children in cages and you see these
bunks and food and and arts and crafts
and things you're really stuck on is
that like Auschwitz it's that really
like a concentration Nazi death camps we
totally overblown the harvesting yeah
history's a lie they just don't know
that we can see it we understand what's
going on and no matter what they say and
it's politically motivated it is just to
get Trump out or in trouble or impeach
because what we're seeing now there's so
many tweets today that I've just been
laughing at well he signed some order so
families could be together but now
families are incarcerated they literally
want a welcome mat go come on in come on
in everyone now make yourselves at home
they've been affected and that's a thing
I'm through trying to find common ground
when they want open borders like well
listen I don't you don't even believe in
deporting felons so let's not talk about
babies and dreamers they want our border
to look like the red carpet to the
Chinese Theater Wow with just as many
pedophiles
you know one thing I will say just just
right now when I just heard you say this
so you just said something about looking
you know camp like and we've talked
about that and here's one thing it
points out to me the right has played
along with this unfortunately because
the left plays in the outrage string and
the right acts like they don't count uh
but they often do like Laura Ingraham
got into a bunch of trouble for saying
something very similar to what you just
said people went after her sponsors but
we've done that in this show and you can
say it what are they what are they gonna
do that like walther firearms they're
not gonna drop us they knew this show
and they signed up that world we're able
now to just say no we're not playing
along but even
the old right guard sometimes bends to
it and that's why I think we lost for so
long
yeah it is difficult and and thank God
there are a few platforms out there
where people could actually speak for me
to be fired this is how difficult it is
for me to be fired from here I have to
get in a time machine go like five
minutes into the future come in and fire
myself see all the way it could be done
I can't be fired so I love it I could
say whatever I want but there's so many
people that have to tiptoe and walk on
those eggshells less you know we've seen
it people get exiled from from the
planet at this point right unless of
course you're Peter Fonda Sony Pictures
just keeps your film and you just go
along your merry way after what he's
saying yeah he's a phone coming out oh
film is coming out it's still greenly
where's the outrage where is that
outrage that tosses him aside cancels
the film we've seen this happen with
Rosanna her show is cancelled for saying
something that was a lot easier to
handle then Barron Trump should be put
in a cage with pedophiles yeah like when
like Peter Fonda said when you say it
out loud like that it almost sounds
off-putting you know it almost does read
in a transcript it's a lot easier
exactly loud like that it almost seems
in poor taste
there's I got outraged by it at all I
really couldn't care less
it's just that they yeah this is one
thing when the the week before that or
the same week people were outraged that
we sent send computer into an LGBTQ AIP
panel to crash it look you're just as
bad as a ladder laughing like wait hold
on just as bad Hannah love
professionally unemployed intersects
errs he's them he left with security he
didn't say he wants a kid of a sitting
president to be raped by a pedophile
liberal yeah it's gonna pass anything
the además righteous anger the same
thing happened with Samantha bee she
kind of half-ass apologize because she
didn't want to really back down from her
statements yeah it was deserved they
when I hear when I hear well they're all
the same
it's the biggest cop-out both sides are
the same it's just it's like no they're
not the left is dangerous there
dangerous if you do something or say
something that doesn't go along with
their line and agenda you can lose your
job your reputation your career
everything you've worked for and it's
gone when you do something that the
right doesn't like wow you're open to
lively debate yes like there's none of
these and I don't even call them
boycotts it's extortion when you see
someone like this David Hogg piece of
crap and he goes and he's trying to get
sponsors pulled from Laura Ingraham show
that's not a boycott they go let the
marketplace decide if you go to sponsors
and threaten them unless they pull their
ads from a show that's not a boycott no
a boycott is when you stop watching
something the ratings go down and the
sponsors go well we're not going to pay
for a low rated show so let's pull the
sponsors you can't come in the mail
better itself yes and just threaten the
sponsors like the Mafia it's like a
Sopranos episode yeah they're walking
into businesses shaking him down or or
they get beaten yeah well we good
contrast there we did a whole segment on
this show celebrating that he was 18 we
could call him a dick and we just ran
through the top ten in sales to David
hog and Wow
I think awesome right it was he looked
like Frankie Muniz had sex for the
soybean guess what
no one's fired us no we're still here
that moves me to the realm of comedy and
we have to get going we had that it's
been too long I've tell you back much
sooner
um yes when I turn into Netflix and it
suggests stand-up specials
I immediately skip it I don't know if
you saw this I can't remember the name
maybe someone can tweet me tusks ride
and help me out cuz now I can't find it
but it was the front you know the
display image on Netflix and on the app
and it was this Australian lesbian fat
comedian and it was a whole the whole
thing is she sits there she tells one
joke and then she goes but I have I have
to retire from comedy because my story
needs to be told and self-deprecation is
not humility its humiliation and then it
flashes across screen New York Times
says a comedy special taking aim at
comedy what why is this a good thing
like the whole point to be is dealing
with paying through humor but now
there's like it's not funny and it's
finally the comedy specials Anthony yeah
a common
cervantes' Nick DiPaolo put it what do
you do I agree wholeheartedly by the way
patton oswalt just put a tweet out last
night about we as comedian we have a
duty to talk about things that will we
can't just do airplane jokes anymore
this is oh so the comedians the ones
that was supposed to be irreverent
against the system make people
uncomfortable they're the ones now that
are supposed to be the voice of reason
you chubby little douche I cannot stand
this guy and say I'm still stuck on duty
[Laughter]
and I hate watch Netflix not the
specials I scroll through I scroll
through the beginning like the the the
either but it's automatic yes yes a
teaser and it's got text on the bottom
it's like a hilarious take on love
political correctness and her job was it
and and I cringe at just the text yeah
and I've done that for four hours I was
like that was this one says she retires
from comedy and takes on toxic culture
much the real rape culture yeah that's
just that's just like watching Eddie
Murphy delirious oh yeah I know it is
just because I know you know that Patton
Oswalt is funny
he's been funny yes yes and if that's
why it's so disappointing it's like when
Mike Myers did the Love Guru is it Mike
Myers or Michael Myers which one's the
holic miler Michael Myers Halloween
confused woody the Love Guru it was so
bad it forced me to go back and gohan a
second was less than powers ever funny
because I thought it was funny growing
up it's kind of like Ninja Turtles then
you realize neutrals was all bad but
there's a new bad humor it's just
they've gotten so political you're going
wait a second was this person ever funny
and it for catalog and that's how it
should be no I really don't like when
somebody's political affiliation or
philosophy gets me to the point where I
don't like them as a performer anymore I
tried
not to do that but when you're saying
that you're gonna like to stop doing
what you do comedic ly to make it more
relevant for politics and the time and
to help the children at the border and
so then I can't I can't bother
I can't bother with you anymore I know
it really is tough there really are only
a handful now you got to me Nick DiPaolo
Wilbur's still unbelievably funny yeah
absolutely
I can't just list now who you really
watch regularly I know it's it's tough
Jim Norton I love Jimmy yeah but Nick
DiPaolo just the other day at Liberty
live in New York got punched in the eye
by a little woman this woman in
Birkenstocks and you know and punched
him right in the face he's got a black
eye and everything because she didn't
like his his brand of humor but that's
the liberal tolerant left he's great I
hear you I hear you laughed at me
getting punched in the eye that's great
I want to do your program again hold on
there buddy when you hear by a lady in
Birkenstocks it was a girl in
Birkenstocks and a little Liddy no the
vagina hat and everything well I know
they can't do that anymore because not
all women have vaginas haven't you heard
yeah yeah haven't we heard that the
insanity the absolute insanity going on
we think like I think back a year ago or
even six months ago it can't possibly
get worse than this and then with the
mental institution throws another set of
doors open and more maniacs come flying
no I know it really but but you know as
comedians there's nothing funny here
it's a dump it's the dump there's
nothing funny about people protesting
the [ __ ] hats because not all women
have vaginas
you couldn't possibly come up with a
premise from that
no no no all right we gotta get going
brother but that is of course the
Anthony Kamiya show on compound media
did I just say it wrong again son of no
that's perfect okay all right and at the
cou Mia show on the Twitter and what's
it what's the YouTube channel as well I
don't know just look up compound media
I'm all over it yes he's all over he
runs it easy some other great show
hey Anthony thank you so much for the
we'll have you back soon Thank You
Stephen
[Music]
oh yeah my morning update isn't the only
ritual baby I just saw a fairy there
right with the finest project Dollar
Shave Club like the amber lavender body
cleanser the pillory shaped lather
I myself splurge for executively and
notice a pilot touch from their premium
hair products like they're smart cap
paste boom again if dollarshaveclub.com
slash crowd or dollarshaveclub.com slash
crowd or $5 get the whole kit it's
awesome
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I think the leader of God said the
people the debtors gonna be taking up a
little Riptide nope it won't happen by
the permission of the Lord my Red Sea
just had its way with well that's pretty
much everyone as it relates to you hey
Anthony Kamiya thank you so much in Ben
Shapiro thank you very much
Charlton Heston terrible actor not a fan
that's something else we'll also get in
the comments section I've gotten more
hate for saying I didn't think Carol
Burnett was funny really I think
anything else yeah yeah I can that yeah
and the Hitler was a liberal socialist
don't think so oh my gosh Bruce Lee it's
gone and everything we said was true
which by the way it's pretty much we
have bas Rutten on the show really comes
weak in Andrew Klavan
and Sebastian Gorka and we have a bunch
of great people coming up to show me
some more change my mind's coming up and
again next week you know the costume
concerts costume contests austenite
sorry and we're we're doing some hidden
camera work here pretty soon some some
stuff that were pretty cool could go
using mischief see yes
well not really miss defection there's
something we're really seeking to
accomplish and it's kind of dangerous
we're not gonna lie to you
we might come in with some black eyes
here at some point very soon and here's
here's the thing um yeah you know you
know I don't wanna I we we usually don't
tell you about this and that's because
hidden cameras can go either way you
never know you know if we if there's no
story we don't really create a story no
I remember I used to be at other news
networks they would do that to make the
footage work yeah make the footage work
so you never know but uh advocate yeah
you deploy your some i fixed it now it's
bad again you had a point before that we
were talking about something that's
really bothering me this week is the
whole the Peter Fonda thing and I'm not
even mad that he you know there is a
blamed hypocrisy that he's like his
movie is alive and well unlike real
Roseanne who was you know yeah removed
from society for much less
in my opinion yeah but it's not really
an opinion yeah it's just kind of I
think saying someone looked like in
someone from Planet of the Apes as far
as a haircut I think is definitively
less severe than saying you hope
someone's child gets raped by pedophiles
when you say it that way yeah I don't
think it's sad but
guess it's opinion I guess we have to
head your bets it's like allegedly
opinion raped by pedophiles bad haircut
but where the pisses me off is this idea
of of righteous anger and they have a
lot of gives have passed to people who
they deem to have righteous anger which
it it's fine there are instances of
righteous anger sure but it has to be
based on truth and if it's not based on
truth it's not you don't get that you
should not you don't earn the righteous
anger pass shouldn't be conceded that
moral high-ground just no no no there
are places in life where the righteous
anger is well warranted you know if your
daughter is getting beat to hell by a
trainee and the texas state wrestling
championship monetized yeah d monetize
and but you know that that's right you
singer you know the the the the dad who
wanted to beat the crap out of the
olympic coach in the in the trial
hearing that's a right thing you're like
okay i I get it yes but it's because
it's not based on a lie so he's all
truth and I think we kind of like to
blur the lines and pretend okay you know
actually be Esme Samantha P had a point
right and it's also based on some
framework of morality
yes Isis that's why they despised Dirty
Harry's of characters you Deathwish
right hey this is racist this is this is
jingoist
this is vigilante this is bad this is
toxic masculinity because they don't
have a foundation they're a moral
framework and yeah I think it said I do
think Peter Fonda had a much better
apology than something earth to be
offered I will give him that much he
didn't really he didn't double down on
saying it was World War two you said he
I was impassioned like many Americans
but doesn't warrant what I said so and
he did apologize yeah yeah I guess so
I appreciate what Ben Shapiro said
earlier about Tommy Robinson yeah like
we do that all the time on this show and
I've seen him do it before and I know
listen Ben can be a little bit of a
know-it-all cuz usually he does
know-it-all but I appreciate that like I
said we have to kind of self-regulate
with that so we do have to hold
ourselves to a bit of a higher standard
yep then say Samantha B or Peter Fonda
but speaking the foundation you know
that's that's a really important thing
and I'm loving the count of the back
here we pre-taped Brian Shaw this week
and again the reason for that is because
we're gonna be doing some hidden camera
stuff on location and so every now and
then we have to pre tape a guest because
it's just we're doing this on a staff of
very reason a staff that's less than
half of just the writers for the Dana
Carvey sketch show to give you an idea
go again watch them their stuff was pure
sheet know their stuff was it their
stuff
some of it was buff yeah but some really
talented people it's funny action right
my dad said you need a watch I said
where you saying we're gonna fail he
said no I'm just saying that comedians
look they used to be these great people
and I was like that's not what I see it
on so no no I'm saying that they're now
they're cowardly and they used to go up
against the networks and this is a great
opportunity for a lot of credit I said I
watch it and I see that hard work and
great talent aren't enough sometimes but
FEMA foundation you've gained some
weight here you we talked about this
with Brian Shaw you've put on 15 pounds
15 to 20 and you've been lifting weights
and eating more and that's been struggle
for you it's been a really icon and I
for the first time ever it been really
committed to consistency yeah I'm seeing
some results small and you have to kind
of you know yourself but I notice I
think I think I think you it's
definitely noticeable to me and several
people have talked about Sarah people in
the comment section actually now watch
are gonna call you a fat son of a [ __ ]
that's tubby but being a foundation you
know that's a important thing what do
you do what are you doing it tip to put
on weight you're eating why am i doing I
am eating a ridiculous amount of
calories and working out three times a
week right doing and lifting heavy stuff
heavy compound heavy heavy combat lifts
and I really do have this this
unbelievable privilege and it's funny
that it's turned into a dirty word but I
use this term as it's meant to be used
to privilege to interview excellent
people often people who are the best at
what they do period in the world so
Brian Shaw is the world Strongest Man
four times I think four or five times
Arnold strongman classic winner which is
another competition but it's it's
basically eight times it's disgusting
how strong and and one of my favorite
interviews I've ever done and will have
that I think here either next week or
the week after and bas Rutten gonna be
next week was a UFC champion king of
Pancrase and so I've had the ability
I've had the luxury the privilege of
picking some of these people's brains
and asking them questions that to me is
what fascinates mean I hope that it I
hope it's something you enjoys a viewer
as opposed to saying so you load of food
we ask those questions too but there are
some really personal questions and I try
to ask these people because I think
people want to know I mean getting into
the mind of someone who's the best at
anything you know even if it were a
soccer player
it's fascinating to me I use that term
loosely in that instance but the
foundation Brian Shaw talked about he
says hey listen there's no you said
there's no magic bullets eating an
insane amount I think you use 12,000
calories a day
and lifting heavy Fozzie it's the same
thing for him effectively as it is for
you now you're never gonna be 6 foot 8
440 pounds but you're still bigger than
you were before with a thousand five
thousand pound deadlift tonight squads
like 909 60-something and I've been
asking a lot of these people this is one
thing until we get a lot of emails this
effect hey I want to go into either
comedy or I want to go into podcasting
how do we do this and listen there are
plenty other people were more successful
who could give you great advice as well
but I can say this and speaking with
people who are the best so Brian Shaw is
a great example just echoed what we've
always heard it starts with a moment
where he said you know what I've
realized I can I couldn't do this when I
competed my first you know he was a he
was a very small 330 pounds back then I
said I realize that I could do it and I
thought okay I can I can compete with
the best of them and then it comes down
to a man it comes down to all the other
stuff so there's a really there's the
same transcending with posture and
buttering start out doing karate he was
bullied as a kid and they need a few
competitions and he's talked about that
that George st. Pierre in the show where
they had a moment that flash of genius
moment where you realized okay you
believe in yourself that you think you
can do this that's where I've talked
about in the past and go back to
previous shows find what you're good
there everyone is excellent at something
you just need to find what it is Brian
Shaw's case it's pretty clear it's plain
to see it might take you a little while
but everyone who's very successful at a
high level I've noticed on this show the
trend is there's that moment of they
believe in themself and that's an
exciting moment I can say that we've had
that with this show we're like you know
what we can do this we can do this
really well and people will really enjoy
this former we set out we didn't know if
we're gonna make a show that anyone
wanted so there's a moment and that's
exciting it's a really exciting moment
and a lot of people aren't aren't
fortunate enough to experience that but
then what's not so exciting is what
comes after that and it's the same thing
with every successful person you see
it's the unsuccessful in-betweens it is
the flash of genius moment I believed in
myself moment which is earned followed
by long unsexy grueling work so Brian
Shaw I had a moment where he said I
think I could I think I could
legitimately if I do my best here become
the World's Strongest Man and then the
answer to that question is
eating 12,000 calories a day lifting
heavy weights monitoring my prot once
resting not once every single day even
when I'm sick when I travel being
disciplined bringing the right food
George st. Pierre when he was in the
show
same thing I realized I could really do
this and then it was conditioning it was
doing neurological training it was doing
game planning that I knew my opponents
weren't doing it was learning how to
live with my fear
it was lifting weight it was fighting it
was sparring every day even when I was
injured same thing with bas Rutten same
thing even if you talk with ventia
pyrrha about academic achievements it
could be anything you can actual it
could be physical but every single one
hasn't it like this is what I realized
about I could do it and then all of this
stuff and if you're lucky enough to have
that moment where you actually believe
in yourself not the lie of self-esteem
but you believe in yourselves you find
out what you're great at doing and
that's wise that's the most important
thing you can do to live a life of
purpose if you're fortunate have to
experience that then comes the unsay and
most people don't experience that and
then the vast majority of people who do
don't do the in-betweens and that is the
difference between the start and
successful it can be really discouraging
to think for me on my I know it could be
years probably years before I really
reach some of my goals
that's not overnight that's the opposite
of overnight but here's what I start
realizing the times gonna pass anyways
might as well have something to show for
it - might as well Count of Monte Cristo
have a few lines on the wall to show you
what Brian Shaw I think is has more
runner-up titles at world strongest men
than anyone in history I believe I
believe three or four times he was
number two and he still imagine that
right if you go ah I don't get the glory
if you're if you haven't accepted the
sexy and the unsexy in-betweens if you
haven't accepted the grueling stuff that
sucks
between your I can do this and success
you're never going to achieve that
success he would write oh if he's
chasing the glory if he's chasing the
fame he's gonna stop it his first number
two let alone his third his fourth and
then rattled off some wins as the
world's strongest freakin myth and I
used this as an example because such a
great guy will probably do some work on
in the future and it's so absolute it's
such a world Strongest Man period well
do you mean he's getting nope he's the
strongest man period well do you mean
that this person is kind of the best
power for no
he's the strongest man
and period okay how did that happen with
every single successful person I have
noticed and I've interviewed a lot of
them it was dawning on me this week it
is a flash of genius moment I believe in
myself which is earned and then doing
the in actually not just doing in
between but then there's a decision
after that the acceptance of this is
going to suck the acceptance of the
in-between because when those glories
when that glory fades SiC transit gloria
right english watch what rushmore when
that glory fades you accepting the
grueling work is the most important
thing because then you're going to do it
day in and day out it's just part of
your job it's just part of your calling
and then it becomes a part of something
that you almost enjoy people talk about
the grind you have all these stupid
motivational speakers on twitter and so
who brings to grind man go out and crush
it but again you're doing it or the boys
okay everyone thinks everyone thinks
it's a beautiful snapshot it's not it
sucks then accepting that is the
accepting suckiness yeah accepting pain
i've noticed once you figured out what
you do well ironically accepting crap
and pain is that first step toward
success I wish you I wish you were more
inspirational but guess what if you want
to be good at anything this is gonna
hurt see you next week
[Music]